[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
ex-minnesota officer 2 tao takes the
stand in his own defense as he and two
other officers stand trial in the death
of george floyd plus he takes a couple
steps and he collapses
are you concerned about your hand or
your husband
oh my husband i knew he was way worse
than me hear from the widow of chad
olson as his accused killer stands trial
for murder and the emotions tonight why
a hefty bond amount remains for the
kenosha man accused of firing his weapon
before kyle rittenhouse but first
reckless behavior
and cost cutting
led to the senseless and tragic death
of helena hutchins a new lawsuit filed
in the deadly russ movie shooting law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the family of the cinematographer
shot and killed by alec baldwin on a
movie set files a wrongful death lawsuit
against baldwin the film's armor and
others law and crimes angie levy is here
with what the suit filed by helena
hutchison's family says
brian helena hutchinson's family claims
in this lawsuit that at least 15
industry standards were ignored on that
movie set and that reckless behavior and
cost cutting contributed to and led to
helena hutchinson's death now you'll
recall that hutchins died last october
after alec baldwin fired a shot as
hutchins was setting a camera shot the
lawyers for hutchinson's husband and son
produced a video recreating what
happened using video animation you can
see that right there on your screen they
also showed text messages from film crew
members from that morning the morning of
the shooting that showed there were
safety concerns on the set baldwin has
said he was told the gun wasn't loaded
that it was cold and that he didn't pull
the trigger now baldwin's claim about
not pulling the trigger has drawn fierce
criticism from armorers and firearms
experts attorney brian panish said
baldwin should have checked the gun to
ensure it wasn't loaded and that he
shouldn't have been using a real gun to
practice a quick draw across draw
well i think it's clear what happened
alec had the gun in his hand he shot it
helena was killed now do we have the
video we don't have it all yet but the
gun cannot fire unless the trigger is
engaged and the hammer is back
so he had the gun he says he pulled the
hammer back it fired she was killed this
is so rare that somebody would be shot
on a scene
when they're lensing it there's nothing
that there's no supposed to be
live ammunition it never should have
happened
never
now this of course is separate from the
police investigation the criminal
investigation into what happened on the
shoot the set of rust being conducted by
the sheriff's office in santa fe new
mexico now alec baldwin's lawyer aaron
dyer released a statement to us saying
that their thoughts and their hearts are
with helena hutchinson's family they
said they go on to cooperate or continue
to cooperate with that criminal
investigation and the investigation
looking into how live ammo ended up on
that set dyer goes on to say though that
actors should be able to rely on
armorers and assistant directors and
others on the set to ensure that a gun
is safe brian
thanks agnet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney taylor coss
and terry austin as we discuss a civil
lawsuit's out of the rush shooting now
taylor aside from hutchinson's lawsuit a
medic is also
making charges for emotional distress in
doing her job my question for you is can
a medic sue
for the distress of helping someone in
the field
thanks for having me guys i think this
uh lawsuit is a stretch um you know when
you sign up to be a medic you know what
you're getting into uh specifically you
are gonna be there to be called on in
stressful and upsetting situations to
provide necessary care so the you know
it's a total surprise to see somebody
who knows what they're getting into and
and if this is what they signed up for
they trained specialized training for
years uh to do this to then say well i
was so emotionally overwhelmed by being
called to do my job then now i'm
entitled to a payday and quite frankly
it does seem like this incident is
sprouting lawsuits left and right from
people who a um either are you know are
necessary part of this process or b
people are kind of on the outside trying
to get theirs and it's really
unfortunate yeah terry maybe you can
give us uh some more of a legal
perspective because factually speaking
taylor 100 agree um tremendous shock
trauma and emotional distress
what exactly does that mean and what
does schaefer this being the medic have
to prove in order to succeed in her
claim
well schaefer is going to have to show
that the armorer the assistant director
the prop master the three individuals
she sued they were negligent and she's
going to have to show that they weren't
reasonable in handling their job she's
also going to have to show that she
suffered this severe emotional distress
that taylor was just referencing and to
show that she's going to have to
introduce medical records demonstrating
that she indeed had trauma and emotional
distress so she's got to document this
emotional distress that she is claiming
she had
hutchins um case is also continuing so
angie let's jump back to those
these cases can take a long time to go
to court how long do the lawyers for
hutchins family believe it will take to
go to trial
and hutchins of course is the film
cinematographer who was killed by alec
baldwin and
her lawyers basically said the lawyers
for her family that in california you
know where they're located
this case could take many many years to
make its way to trial but they believe
because they filed it in santa fe county
where this occurred
that basically
you know this could be going to trial in
one to two years so it sounds like at
least at this point they're looking
forward to a trial and they're looking
forward they said when they discussed
this at the press conference to
gathering more information and obtaining
more discovery including the video from
the set when the shooting happened
however long it takes law and crime will
be there to give you that gavel to gavel
coverage to make sure you have updates
on this the deadly rush shooting
a settlement is reached in the prince
andrew sex abuse lawsuit brought on by
accuser virginia duffrey court documents
reveal the lawsuit was settled outside
of court and the settlement amount was
not disclosed this comes after prince
andrew failed to get the lawsuit thrown
out and was stripped of his military
titles and british royal honors drewfrey
alleges prince andrew sexually assaulted
her when she was only 17 years old under
the guise of the now deceased jeffrey
epstein and his longtime girlfriend
elaine maxwell who has since been
convicted of federal sex trafficking
crimes a release statement reads in part
quote prince angie regrets his
association with epstein and commends
the bravery of mrs dufrey and other
survivors this settlement means the
lawsuit will likely be dismissed by a
federal judge
also in federal court a jury finds the
new york times is not liable in the
defamation lawsuit brought by sarah
palin this one day after judge jed
rakhoff ruled palin's legal team had not
met the legal standard required to prove
the new york times defamed her in an
editorial announcing he planned to
dismiss the case that means had jurors
were ruled in favor of palin the verdict
would be tossed out regardless palin the
former governor of alaska and one-time
vice presidential nominee argues the
times defamed her in 2017 in an article
the article linked palin to a masked
2011 shooting in arizona but the
editorial was corrected just 12 hours
later
still ahead on law and crime daily a
florida widow takes the stand to recount
the moments leading up to the deadly
shooting of her husband but first months
after the reign house acquittal court is
back in session with judge bruce
schroeder why he says bond will remain
as is in the case against joshua
zaminski
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
wisconsin judge dismisses the motion to
lower bond for the man who fired a gun
before kyle rain house opened fire
amidst the kenosha riots in 2020.
thirty-six-year-old joshua zaminski
faces multiple charges including arson
disorderly conduct use of a dangerous
weapon and obstructing an officer for
his involvement in the riots the right
stem from the shooting of jacob blake a
black man by a white officer they gained
national attention after a then
17-year-old kyle renthouse shot and
killed two people and injured a third
claiming self-defense last year reyna
house was acquitted of all charges bond
for zuminsky was originally set at one
thousand dollars but bumped up to
fourteen thousand after an altercation
with nathan de bruyne a kenosha
wisconsin photographer and witness in
the written house trial it happened at
the kenosha county courthouse where de
bruyne was set to testify zaminski now
faces possible witness intimidation
charges on monday kenosha county
assistant district attorney thomas
binger explained what happened in the
altercation
what occurred is that mr de bruin was
walking in with this large photograph
mr zaminski
yelled out to him something along the
lines of stop you're not an attorney i
want to see that photograph
mr debroon did not respond although he
made eye contact with mr zaminski but
didn't say anything in response
immediately went inside and reported it
this was captured on uh the video out in
front of the courthouse that's up on the
roof it was also captured by mr darun's
girlfriend on a cell phone none of that
video has any audio so the only
rendition we have of what was said is
from mr debroon and
anyone else that might have heard it
the
interaction that occurred according to
mr debrun was maybe five or six seconds
in length and they were about five to
six feet apart at the closest that this
occurred
according to prosecutors a report on the
incident will be released in the near
future right now zyminsky is being held
in custody jury selection in his
upcoming trial is set for next month
back to break down the latest of the
kenosha court in criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and terry austin
terry we heard the numbers there from a
thousand to fourteen thousand dollars
one for riding the next for alleged
threat of a photographer can you make
heads or tails as to why in terms of
that dollar amount
i can't both amounts are relatively
minor if you ask me and both charges
actually are minor in comparison to a
murder charge say for instance and the
whole purpose of bail brian is to
protect the community just in case the
defendant is going to commit the act
again or to keep him from fleeing
whether it's a thousand dollars or
fourteen thousand dollars i don't think
it is going to prevent this individual
from either one of those things so i'm
not really sure why they have bail at
all in this case yeah taylor with trial
push back to march 28th if witness
tampering charges are filed i'm not
quite sure they will be but how would
that work out with this trial
so if witness tampering charges are
filed we're talking about more delay
because this is going to be near
impossible for them to incorporate this
witness's testimony into any trial
without going into the underlying facts
of these new charges so what will likely
happen is if they do bring these charges
they're going to try to have to
incorporate them into the same charging
instrument as zaminski's now facing this
is only going to delay the case even
further all right let's hope not that
march 28th date is something our viewers
want to check out if not as you said the
word of the day taylor delay uh let's
hope that doesn't happen coming up on
law on crime daily an ex-minnesota
police officer takes the stand as he
faces federal charges in the death of
george floyd plus eight years after her
husband was shot and killed a florida
widow takes the stand describing what
led up to the deadly shooting
[Music]
welcome back we head now to florida in
the case of retired police captain
curtis reeves who allegedly shot and
killed chad olson in a movie theater
eight years ago as the victim's wife
nicole takes the stand nicole was seated
next to her husband in the wesley chapel
movie theater on january 13 2014 when
the shooting occurred reeves says he was
getting frustrated after olson being on
his cell phone while the movie trailers
played ahead of the film
there's been debate between attorneys
over what olson was doing on his cell
phone the story over the years has been
that he was texting the babysitter who
was watching the couple's daughter at
home now both sides have said he was on
facebook and surfing the web olson's
wife told the jury what happened just a
few feet away from her when her husband
was shot
after he returned from getting
management and he stated i see you put
your phone away now that i went to get
management
chad again said what is your problem and
he did state that he was checking on a
message about his daughter do you ever
see your husband standing and turning
towards mr reeves and throwing a cell
phone
do you
hear any cussing swearing or f-bombs by
your husband
after you both began to stand up and you
were fully standing you knew you were
hurt you knew he was hurt where was he
he was
coming here
and start stumbling
down the aisle away from
what are you doing at that point
your hands burn figuring out what
happens i
i mean i knew
a shotgun rang out but i didn't know
where he was shot or what
really what our injuries were other than
my hand felt like it was gone
off of my arm and i'm watching him
collapse so i know it's bad
it's just shock i think panic
criminal defense attorney taylor coss
and co-host terry austin are back to
discuss uh mrs resort nicole's testimony
in the movie theater murder terri i was
waiting for someone to finally show us
how loud people were or the the the
acoustics in the theater theater was how
did jane roy convey that to the jury
well jane roy was one of the witnesses
in that theater and she was also a great
witness like mrs olson and the reason
she was so great is because she stood up
not just on direct but on
cross-examination as well she had a loss
of sight and loss of hearing from a
stroke but the attorney for the defense
was trying to impeach her credibility
because she originally said that it was
loud in the previews and now she's
saying it was louder when the movie came
on and one of the things she did was she
said well this is loud but this is even
louder so i thought she was excellent
yeah now taylor looking at mrs olsen
she's uniquely an eyewitness and a
character witness to her husband how did
her testimony on both help the
prosecution's case
well you know she's first of all she's
got the prime viewing for what happened
she was a part of the entire incident
from start to finish so she's in a great
great position to narrate the events uh
to the jury and so they're looking at
her and they're saying this is great
information and then as a bonus she can
tell the jury who her husband was what
he was like and what he was likely to do
and not do in those type of situations
so i thought she was tremendous she was
poised and i thought she was a very very
successful witness for the prosecution
we'll see how that how they use her
testimony in the summation because
that's all it is it's building blocks up
to that summation to see what the jury
decides to end the day and will continue
to follow this case make sure to watch
the law and crime network for galileo
coverage of florida versus curtis reeves
when we come back the defense begins its
case in the federal trial of three
ex-minnesota police officers which
officer was first to take the stand as
he has tried for the death of george
floyd
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
witness testimony begins in the federal
hate crimes trial of the three men
convicted in the death of ahmad arbury
on monday jurors heard opening
statements from both sides prosecutors
say gregory mcmichael travis michael and
william roddy brian targeted a mod
arbory because he was black they also
presented a history travis mcmichael had
with using racial slurs defense
attorneys countered saying travis and
michael's slurs were unrelated to
aubry's death saying he and his father
were attempting to protect their
neighborhood last fall the mcmichaels
and brian were convicted in aubry's 2020
death at the time the 25 year old black
man was jogging near his brunswick
georgia home gregory and travis
mcmichael tailed aubry in a pickup truck
claiming they believed he was
responsible for a series of robberies in
their neighborhood trousing michael
eventually shot and killed aubry
claiming a since repealed and replaced
citizen's arrest brian followed along in
his own truck and recorded the incident
on video all three were sentenced to
life in prison brian is eligible for
parole after 30 years the mcmichaels
will serve an additional 20 years after
their life sentence the federal trial is
expected to last up to 10 days
also in federal court ex-officer 2 tao
takes a stand in his own defense as he
and two other former officers stand
trial in connection to the death of
george floyd tu tau thomas lane and jay
alexander king are on trial for the at
the federal level for allegedly
depriving floyd of his constitutional
rights when they failed to give him
medical help or intervene when their
fellow former officer derek chauvin
knelt on his neck floyd died shortly
after the incident and showman was
convicted for his murder on monday the
prosecution rested its case that's when
tao and king indicated they planned to
testify on tuesday lane confirmed he
planned to testify as well on the stand
tuesday tao described the police
training he received in 2009 jurors were
shown a photo of officers kneeling on a
subject to handcuff and restrain them he
also told jurors it was his job to
handle the crowd that day that floyd was
killed allowing the other officers to
quote attend to mr floyd i was assuming
they were taking care of him king lane
and tau also face a separate state trial
in connection to floyd's death that's
set to happen in june
taylor i was focused on the crowd i
didn't know what was happening
sounds like the best defense any of the
officers could have do you think it will
work though
i like it i actually like it because uh
it gives a viable excuse for why he
wasn't paying attention to what was
going on behind him it is common sense i
look i had to face the crowd there are
dangerous people potentially here i have
to keep an eyes out but more importantly
if his attorney can bolster his client's
testimony with police training manuals
with police handbooks that show that one
officer has to be in this position
facing the crowd at all times so that he
was just doing his job he's got a chance
yeah i think it's the best chance of
them all and i'm interested to see how
it plays out terry now we know that all
the defendants will testify we'll
hearing from all of them hurt the
prosecution's case
i think it could hurt the prosecution's
case and this is why you have three
police officers who are brave enough to
get on that stand and say what it was
that was going on at the time of this
incident they're saying i'm not afraid
to get up and defend myself and as we
just heard we know that tao is saying
that he was just managing the crowd
that's a decent argument they're all
going to say this is what they were
trained to do of course
king is going to claim that he was not
only trained but he was following orders
i think he has the most difficult case
as far as the defense is concerned
and i think that one of the better cases
lane might have a decent case because he
essentially is going to say that he told
derek tobin to please roll floyd over on
his side he's also going to say he
thought that there could be some
delirium and he tried to administer some
medical aid in that ambulance so he has
a decent chance all right we'll see how
this plays out as all of them testifying
summations come up thank you both and
also thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you